♪
>> Jesse: MORE PROOF THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE THE PARTY HAD
AWOKE, SHOWING A SEISMIC SHIFT
IN THE ELECTORATE, DEMOCRATS ARE
INCREASINGLY IDENTIFIED AS
HIGHLY EDUCATED HOITY-TOITY
TYPES THAT WILL CHECK YOU FOR
USING THE WRONG PRONOUNS WHILE
REPUBLICANS ARE CONFORMING WITH
A DIVERSE WORKING CLASS BASE.
CHECK OUT THIS CIVIL EXCHANGE,
JOSH HAWLEY FACING OFF WITH A
BERKELEY LAW PROFESSOR, GREG
WENT THERE OVER WHO CAN GET
PREGNANT.
WATCH.
>> YOU REFER TO PEOPLE WITH A
CAPACITY FOR PREGNANCY, WOULD
THAT BE WOMEN?
>> SO I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
YOUR LINE OF QUESTIONING IS
TRANSPHOBIC AND IT OPENS UP
TRANS TO VIOLENCE BY NOT
RECOGNIZING THEM.
>> I AM OPENING UP PEOPLE TO
VIOLENCE WHETHER OR NOT ASKING
IF WOMEN ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE A PREGNANCY.
YOU ARE DENYING TRANS PEOPLE.
IT'S BECAUSE THAT'S HOW YOU RUN
YOUR QUESTION THOUGH IN MY
CLASSROOM, ARE STUDENTS ALLOWED
TO QUESTION NEO, OPENING PEOPLE
UP TO VIOLENCE.
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU THINK
THAT CLASS IS REALLY?
>> Greg: YES, YOU BETTER BE AN
LOCKSTEP OR YOU'RE ARE DEAD.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING STAYING THERE
FOR A SPECIFIC ISSUE IS THE END
OF DEBATE.
WHEN YOU'RE FACED WITH SOMEONE
WHO IS NOT ARGUING A POINT, BUT
EMPLOYING A REDEFINED WORD, THEN
YOU CAN'T DEBATE THEM, BECAUSE
THE WORD THEY USED IS INVENTED
BASED ON AN ARTIFICIAL REALITY
WHICH IS PREGNANT MAN, PREGNANT
MAN IS A FALLACY.
IT IS NOT REAL, BUT YOU CAN'T
EVEN GO FURTHER IN THE DEBATE
BECAUSE SHE IS SAYING, NO,
THAT'S THE FINAL SAY, I HAVE
INVENTED THIS WORD IT'S REAL.
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE AND ALL
DEBATES, YOU CAN'T GET THEM TO
ADDRESS THEIR OWN INVENTED
TERMINOLOGY.
INSTEAD THEY THROW THE TERMS AT
YOU AND SAY THAT'S HOW IT IS.
THINK ABOUT IT THOUGH, WHEN --
THIS WAS DURING A HEARING ON
ABORTION I BELIEVE, WHEN WAS THE
LAST TIME WE ACTUALLY HAD A
DEBATE ON ABORTION?
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
ARGUMENTS OF CHOICE OR AUTONOMY
OR LIMITS, BUT THE ACT OF
ABORTION ITSELF?
A REAL PHILOSOPHICAL PUBLIC
DEBATE ON WHAT IS LIFE?
WHEN DOES LIFE BEGIN?
WHAT DOES SCIENCE HAVE TO SAY?
WHY DON'T WE DO THAT?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE ARE
ALWAYS DEBATING ABOUT THE
CHOICE, WHICH IS RHETORIC OR
ABOUT --
WE NEVER ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT THE
THING.
IT'S LIKE GOING TO A CARD
DEALERSHIP, TERRIBLE ANALOGY AND
HE WENT TO BUY A CERTAIN CAR,
BUT HE KEEPS POINTING AT OTHER
CARS, TELL ME ABOUT THIS AND NO
ONE WANTS TO DO IT.
WHY IS THAT?
IT IS TOO FRIGHTENING I GUESS.
>> Jesse: IF YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT AT
THE TOP, IF YOU ARE SEEING THAT
AS A REGULAR MIDDLE-CLASS PERSON
IN INDIANA AND YOU SEE SOMEONE
OUT THERE TALKING ABOUT
TRANSPHOBIC VIOLENCE, ARE YOU
GOING TO VOTE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IF THEY ARE
ASSOCIATING WITH A WING NUT LIKE
THAT?
>> Martha: THAT IS WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING ABOUT THE SHIFT IN
THE COUNTRY AND THIS, IT IS
SHOWING THAT PEOPLE REGULAR
FOLKS CANNOT RELATE TO THAT
CONVERSATION AT ALL.
AND THEY LOOK AT JOSH HAWLEY AND
THEY ARE LIKE, YES, HE IS JUST
ASKING THE VERY REASONABLE
QUESTION OF --
IT JUST GOES BACK TO WHAT IS A
WOMAN?
DURING THE SUPREME COURT HEARING
AND YOU TURN TO THIS
CONVERSATION AND GO, THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
TALK TO ME ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
IS RELATABLE THAT MEAN SOMETHING
TO THEM.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE ELECTORATE, YOU
SEE THAT THERE IS THE ELITE
PARTY HAS BECOME THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
AND I SORT OF SEE THIS SHIFT IN
2016, YOU START TO SEE THAT THE
SIGNS FOR HILLARY CLINTON WERE
ON THE LAWNS OF THE MOST WEALTHY
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE WORLD, IN
THE COUNTRY, AND THEN THE
BODEGAS WERE PUTTING UP SIGNS
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NUC THIS SHIFT WITH HISPANIC
VOTERS, THE SHIFT WITH BLACK
VOTERS AND YOU SEE THAT PEOPLE
WANT SOMEONE TO MEET ONE WHERE
THEY ACTUALLY ARE INSTEAD OF
TALKING PASS THEM AND I THINK
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS GOTTEN
CAUGHT UP IN THIS WEB IN A WAY
THAT IS NOT HELPFUL TO HIM.
NOW HE HAS THIS GROUP DOING
THESE #Don'tRunJoe AND THEY
BASHED HIM, HE IS NOT IN-LINE
ENOUGH.
HE IS JUST GOING TO GET SMACKED
AROUND BY THIS KIND OF
CONVERSATION AND HE HAS A MOMENT
AND A CHOICE TO DECIDE IF HE IS
GOING TO PUT HIMSELF BACK IN
THAT MODERATE MAP AND GET BACK
TO WHAT HE WAS ALL ABOUT IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THAT HAPPEN
YET, BUT I THINK THAT SOME OF
THESE NUMBERS OUGHT TO BE PUT IN
FRONT OF HIM BY PEOPLE THAT
REALLY CARE ABOUT THEM AND
REALLY WANT HIM TO -- IF THEY
REALLY WANT HIM TO RUN AGAIN.
I DON'T KNOW WHATEVER PERCENTAGE
IS.
>> Jesse: HOW DANGEROUS IS
THIS MIGRATION INTO THE
HOITY-TOITY LAND OF POSTGRADUATE
DEGREE GENDER-NEUTRAL SITUATION
THAT YOU GUYS ARE DRIFTING INTO
WHEN MOST OF THE COUNTRY HAS A
HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE, WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE?
>> Jessica: PEOPLE THAT
JOE BIDEN WON BACK IN 2020 HE
DID BETTER THAN HILLARY HAD DONE
AND BARACK OBAMA HAD DONE.
WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN TO THE
ELECTION YET OR HAD THE MIDTERM,
BUT THE IMPACT OF THESE
WOKE-STIR MOMENTS.
THE AVERAGE PERSON IS NOT
WATCHING THESE HEARINGS IN THE
AVERAGE PERSON THINKS OF
JOSH HAWLEY AND THEY REMEMBER
HIM FOR STANDING OR WALKING BY
THE PEOPLE WHO BECAME THE
CAPITOL HILL WRITERS ON
JANUARY 6.
JOSH HAWLEY, RON DeSANTIS,
TOM COTTON, THEY ARE ALL FAKE.
POPULIST FAKE.
THEY ALL GO TO IVY LEAGUE
SCHOOLS, THEY ARE FANCIER THAN I
AM FOR EVERYBODY WHO LIKES TO
MAKE FUN OF ME FOR MY IRISH
BACKGROUND.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE FANCIER
THAN YOU ARE?
>> Jessica: THEY ARE FANCIER
THAN I AM.
LET ME READ THIS.
THIS IS IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
IF YOU KNOW YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
A PREGNANT WOMAN, BY ALL MEANS
CALL HER THAT.
IF YOU KNOW YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT SOMEONE WHO IS PREGNANT
AND NOT A WOMAN, DRESSED SOMEHOW
THEY WANT TO BE ADDRESSED.
YOU ARE GOING TO --
YOU ARE GAINING SEVEN EXTRA
SYLLABLES AND I PROMISE YOU ARE
LOSING NOTHING.
AND THERE IS SOMETHING TO
TREATING PEOPLE WITH DIGNITY.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU THINK THAT
TRANS PEOPLE ARE RIDICULOUS IN
THAT IT IS MADE UP, IF THERE IS
A TRANS MAN WHO IS LIVING HIS
LIFE LIKE THIS, HE IDENTIFIES
THAT WAY, HE WORKS HIS JOB AND
HAS A FAMILY AND WANTS TO GO AND
HAVE CHILDREN, THE GREATEST GIFT
THAT HE CAN AND HE HAS NOT HAD
GENDER REASSIGNMENT SURGERY,
THEN CALL HIM --
>> Jesse: ARE DRIFTING INTO A
LAND.
>> Dagen: THAT IS NOT WHAT WE
JUST SAW.
WHAT YOU SAW WAS FROM THAT'S A
LAW PROFESSOR IF YOU DON'T AGREE
WITH ME, AND REGURGITATE THE
LANGUAGE THAT I SAY YOU HAVE TO
USE, THEN YOU ARE STOKING
VIOLENCE AND YOU ARE EVIL.
AND WE WITNESSED IN THAT ONE
LITTLE CLIP, WHICH THE WHOLE
WORLD WILL SEE BECAUSE IT WAS ON
"THE FIVE" ON DISPLAY IS HOW
THIS LEFT-WING LUNACY GERMINATED
AND HOW IT SPREAD.
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES,
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN FORCE-FED
THIS AND THREATENED BY THESE
DICTATORIAL PROFESSORS THAT IF
THEY DID NOT REGARD TO RATE THIS
CLAPTRAP IN SCHOOL, YOU'RE NOT
GETTING YOUR DEGREE AND OUT OF
SCHOOL WHEN THEY ENTER THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
CONSULTANTS THAT ARE MAKING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR SELLING THIS GARBAGE
TO PEOPLE ACROSS THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THIS IS HOW IT HAPPENS.
AND REGULAR FOLKS WHO WANT THEIR
KIDS TO GET REALLY GOOD COLLEGE
EDUCATION WATCH THAT AND GO, AM
I PAYING OR BORROWING 100 GRAND
TO GET A LAW SCHOOL DEGREE FROM
THAT WOMAN?
AM I GOING TO PAY A FOUR YEAR
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE OUT OF
STATE FOR $300,000 AND ITS
LITERALLY EVERY SINGLE
UNIVERSITY AND COLLEGE ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET FOR YOUR
DEGREE.
NO MORE.
>> Greg: I HAVE A QUESTION,
HAS ANYBODY EVER ASKED HOW MANY
PREGNANT MEN ARE THERE?
HOW MANY?
>> Dagen: IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
>> Jessica: NOT MANY, SO LEAVE
THEM ALONE.
>> Greg: WE ARE BEING CAN PELT
TO CHANGE OUR LANGUAGE FOR SEVEN
PEOPLE.
AND A THOUSAND PEOPLE, I AM
SORRY, YOU DON'T CHANGE THE
LANGUAGE AND TAKE THE PRONOUN
THEY TO DESCRIBE IT TO A SINGLE
PERSON, THAT IS LUNACY.
>> Jesse: AND WE ARE BEING
VIOLENCE.
>> Jessica: MORE --
>> Martha: THERE IS A VERY
SMALL UNIVERSE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS THAT PEOPLE DO
TREAT PEOPLE WITH RESPECT.
YES, THEY DO.
AND MOST PEOPLE ARE RESPECTFUL
OF PEOPLE'S CHOICES IN LIFE, AND
WHEN THEY LOOK AT THIS, THEY
SAY, WHAT?
YES, THEY ARE CONFRONTED WITH
THE SITUATION I BELIEVE MOST
PEOPLE ARE RESPECTFUL.
>> Dagen: DON'T BE A SCIENCE
DENIER.
>> Jesse: JOSH HAWLEY